okay PayPal it's your boy psychobabble
time we're playing this game called does
a great rest right here well I think the
game was followed by or what but we'll
say okay yes of course there's no
continuing game okay
because this is me
whoa what's up with my like back leg and
her legs all jacked up
I'd say that is not a foul but an
affable adventure yes you know I guess I
agree and they can no longer die before
they are like the angels some kind of
looks at that motor give you a little
angel you know I guess he's come on here
sleep on now and take care of rest matt
said that that get Matt's a good guy and
man you find comfort in the arms of an
angel how long is this thing I got out
there like I'm getting soaked here get
him real sucked by this right I got it's
a cake uh yeah okay path a path name
I am so sorry
[Music]
by the side
[Music]
it's on my radio but they're all pretty
garbage eh you know
[Music]
it's weird it's in like window screens
are like widescreen was like still
showing up up there yeah that's him
better got sat before it catch up comp
man okay that's all right I can't go
this way I can't go this light I say
this
no well you got the carpet one night man
this guy's bother looking no neck like
almost no legs he just like all body
what is this her hair should clean that
mess up sometime huh no so count yeah
that's the worst letter ever seen and I
read most of them already
I need something to light it with
wish anyhow to fix this okay a recce
looking guy
I'm gonna go crazy with this thing
back what
out of that nice nap our
when does our cage right
someone's entrapped break someone's got
me stuck in here and I like that the
doors locked at the help yeah this
attacked had a derrick
and missus up I never had another over
there but think I want the right at a
time yeah well but Jack except now we
got one last door okay so what's going
on here man this guy is where could I
look it I gotta clean that up too
disgusting
mmm is it laundry room is that enter
that password it just want a threat like
a headache at Eddie get out here the
skeptic another and well bunch okay
gotta get a password got to get a
password it's gonna not over here what
is that
they got wreath urethra well that's good
that got me so it's one eight one eight
that's it
right hey check this that's right
one a on it but think you don't saying
one eight everywhere eight and one
so it's one eight one one eight eight
one that it it goes this room
take Kay
Vanessa I was like locked here yeah yeah
I think it's over here you guys this
most locked
okay hey like a fun oh my god let's get
the heck outta me
wow that really scared right Jesus is
that blood and now it's a marinara sauce
cars it's blood
I went to all this right nothing but
what
come back in time or something that's my
way how's their day is very average
tiring as always I mean you know hard as
them do i how can you stand working for
them and you now have bad things all
right
and we're all working for them at all of
us stop with that nonsense honey like
stop it like don't you ever question but
what I question what don't you ever say
that okay we're not supposed to question
okay everything is hit well and in order
I can't get that one day where they
believe in all of us yep epic ah summer
Scientologists we do what we have to to
survive yes but she got dying out as a
way scary the power's out again oh you
got checking out place yeah I'll be back
in a minute okay I got check it out cuz
apparently that's all I'm good for
my back this is disgusting
hello
yeah
thank God I'm here
it's reeking like a hit a slope like
don't trust that guy right there
okay weird
what's all this trash like on it's
locked
hey where are these people oh holy crap
skinny annoying at least dog people how
are you I hope everything's okay I had
you guys fine but was it all about and
just forget about it and he said dogs
I really shouldn't okay I guess the
basement is where like the circuit
breaker being sewn ticklin I Spy
something yeah you know I gray what the
hell was that how was that guy
wait what is going on here
that's look Rapids and I you know we had
a good time yeah yes yes I want to say
that good
is there a bad there's a fox naso no and
they can't remember or forget what I
remember what
disgusting this guy's like definitely a
drunk he's a drug okay I've said to Jax
w saying
now okay this is horrifying
scary myself all the bear crap
that's fair one and I will fix happen to
merciful way okay is all messed up but
okay
bracken Bono's you know why my dad like
I wish I had some cons I'm at nothing
you don't have any coins
you just have a low Mary Jesus lady
found Jeff bucks and some financial
documents okay
perhaps over here just more documents
like there's so many documents here like
who is doing all these documents like oh
my god
all right I thought this blood hair okay
take sword shot
okay so I got Jesus right here but I and
a sword shard well I just how long they
got me thank got me yeah what the heck
all right
the drawer is stuck I need something to
pry it you know
part of Arkansas it looks old
yeah so our shard oh my god
okay Jesus
mmm-hmm no a pretty slow
about 300
right there there's an angel statue I
don't know okay you know there's so many
unanswered questions yeah I know right
this way
oh my static I'll take care of our guy
throws [ __ ] about magazines okay I get
it you know I get it all right I gotta
go each other right okay baby I gotta go
all the way to the right and while this
character is going this way I'm just
gonna check my text messages you know
because you know why not uh-huh
okay
yeah they said the one picked up a king
okay
I honestly I don't hear everywhere that
he goes oh Jesus
something like ten hours to get back
Juan doesn't have dropped me off in the
middle this is sound I my man never I go
what room is this
rather we never go in there again it
takes like ten hours
you tell you see that was locked wasn't
like at the end nothing we looked that
special the Angels Chester just like on
the John okay
very confusing look at this low guy he's
gone he's really gone it's like you're
so awake that cooked crab legs feel
pretty bad about that you're hydrating
here yeah
that's their methods on kids not working
it fine
good luck I need a kid out but it can't
wait out here
hey I got the LA bike I got the house at
now I got the house at now Jimmy
various happen that great no I was long
always you can take like 10 years yeah
Terry I want to take you how's that nice
it's not that
oh great they got me
and I got me trapped oh my god what
[Music]
okay this is so jacked up they where
they got me they got me good
I know Oh what the heck of that watch I
have a three out of seven I got there
right
okay they await away it's a time
yeah I'm actor
a knight thatcher his sword is broken
okay
that's the lecture there's nothing here
okay
I see her performing very well I'm stare
at camp
let's jelly I should give you our lied
at that game I guess
and in Samantha's a said I'm a man a say
slow down that's is just the beginning
or is it maybe you all remember
everything and time maybe not what are
you talking about oh this feels like a
dream
yeah it just sounded like the others
well uh he said others how the others
say that that enough
I thank you I've got sent out and then
kiss his place gets to use it well
enough chitchat after life and you're
ready to remember what kind of man you
here oh my god
[Music]
all right so well I won this hair
actually kept get back to home alright
thanks for watching y'all see in the
next episode y'all bye bye